From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
[ How to Request Materials Online
at the Library of Congress ]
Once you have your Library of
Congress reader identification card,
you are ready to begin requesting
books and other materials,
for use in the reading rooms.
This video will walk you through
the request process, step by step.
Let's get started by
looking at an example.
From the Library of
Congress homepage,
I will navigate to
the Library Catalog.
You will notice there are a number
of available search options.
Today, I will use the Quick Search,
located at the top of the page.
After I type in a title,
author, or keyword,
I will hit enter to continue.
Looking through the results,
I have found an item I
might want to request.
So, I will click on the
title for more information.
If I decide that I would
like to request this item,
I will click on "Where to Request"
to determine the items
location and availability.
The record indicates that I
should "Request In" the Jefferson
or Adams Building Reading Rooms.
Since I will be working from
the Main Reading Room located
in the Jefferson Building,
I know that I should be
eligible to request this item.
Next, I will select "Request
this Item," to continue.
I will enter my last name and
account number as they appear
on my reader identification card.
Then, I will enter my
password and select "Login."
If this is your first online
request, you will need to set
up your account by logging
in with the default password
that the library provided to you.
You will then be prompted
to create your own password
to use for future log-ins.
If you did not receive
the default password
or you need help logging in,
click on "Forgot Your Password?"
Or, contact reader
registration for assistance.
This is the request form.
Under "delivery location", select
the reading room where you would
like your item delivered.
Please note, not every reading
room uses the online request form.
Only those reading
rooms listed under
"delivery locations" allow
items to be requested online.
When you have finished
filling out the request form,
select "Send request" to continue.
If you properly submitted the form,
you will receive the following
message: "request successful."
Once you submit the request,
you can expect to wait anywhere
from 30-90 minutes for the material
to be delivered to the reading room.
The amount of time for material
delivery will vary based
on the items format and location,
and the access policies
of the reading room.
Requests for materials that
are stored off-site can take
up to the next business day.
To save time, you may wish
to request your items online
before you arrive at the library.
Materials will be held for 48
hours at the Book Service desk.
If you wish to request items earlier
than 48 hours before your arrival,
speak with a reference
librarian for assistance.
And remember, the national
library is your library.
We hope to see you soon.
This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.GOV.